[Musique]
depuis 2011 l'année de la création de
l'icône hotech lé département avait un
objectif le rayonnement de cet outil sur
l'océan indien
et ce jour là si territoire était en
live pour partager cette première
exposition virtuelle commune une banque
d'image de nos territoires
mesdames messieurs qui sont présents
écran je vous remercie et que nous avons
en commun ils marquent patrimoniaux fort
magnifique projet de ce qu'on appelle
une coopération régionale dans notre
jargon qui associe donc des pays donc de
l'océan indien de langues différentes
avec cependant une forte prédominance
donc francophones qu'il faut là aussi ça
fait parce que c'est aussi tout ce
patrimoine culturel commun comme vous le
disiez qui est qui célébrait et qui est
porté devant le monde entier
effectivement puisque d'être sur une
plate forme de partage alors on le voit
déjà nous dans les réseaux sociaux qui a
une appétence de madagascar sur facebook
par exemple un stage sur instagram ce
sont les mauriciens qui viennent nous
consulter donc c'est toute cette
pertinence dans les échanges
et dans cette culture commune qu'on
appelle communément l'indian océanie et
le travail historique et l'onp récolté
analysé numérisés catalogué diffusé
l'histoire nécessite de la méthode
d'autres ponts se font par la culture
dans l'océan indien à travers notamment
les résidences d'artistes et les le
patrimoine c'est un patrimoine très
partagée et que à travers cet outil il y
à une lisibilité du patrimoine de la
zone océan indien et du sud ouest de
l'océan indien qui peut être partagé et
en même temps qui peut être lisible est
connu à travers le monde entier nous
avons tous un destin commun et que ça
c'est notre force
à terme c'est plus de 2000 images qui
pourront être consultables de quoi
illustrer notre culture commune et nos
différences car unis c'est forcément
plus facile de parler au reste du monde
[Musique]